we're still white so white we still
don't know what new growth means they
put jokes right alongside with real
critiques
hello math much juice science narrator
is a pedantic pontificating pretentious
bastard a belligerent old fart a
worthless steaming pile of cow dung
I heard they masturbate you know why he
stopped writing books because he
masturbates cinemasins more like cinema
Sims am i right they've never made a
movie therefore they should shut the
fuck up one of them has seen office
Christmas party 18 times while still not
having once watched Gone with the Wind
shut the door we're not critics we're
assholes but our closest friends still
come up and ask hey what's your next
move you're gonna review so I guess
we're both critics and assholes I knew
it I'm surrounded by assholes that said
one of us is literally a critic
we've now inspired over 13,000 YouTube
channels to make explainer videos on how
much we suck leading YouTube to create a
new processing farm just for cinemasins
sucks channels the land of which was
once dedicated to solving climate change
our video and Kong Skull Island
single-handedly kept the movie from a
7.0 rating on the IMDB
we've been compared to Donald Trump at
least twice publicly but we've never
colluded with Russia but cosmid
Regenerist ing merge the cupola me why's
coming back on the Catherine II
brushless a Theresa Koon there they say
nobody is without sin but they keep
refusing to sin Jesus of Nazareth are
you not worth more than they they say
you know will be is without sin so why
haven't they done march of the Penguins
already oh man this is why the CIA is no
place for a woman that's racist they
call things racist that are clearly
sexist or ages but not racist
and that's fascist they eat with their
hands how do you eat it if your hands
rumor has it they just scope out the
IMDB goofs section and make videos based
on that they tweet like normal weirdos
which is clearly an act they've staged
over 174 episodes of their podcast I
make it sound like they love movies just
as a cover for their blatant hate of all
movies that is obvious and clear in the
sense videos big recommend for me the
changeling the original George C Scott
oh really it's like it called classic
this is a really good movie we've
interviewed several people involved in
the movie industry and they act
don't hate us we think they're sjw's one
of us seriously likes GI Joe rise of the
Cobra I mean Jesus we genuinely affect
our movies are made logos really long
and dramatic logos holy Libby is amazing
at watching cinemasins by the way what
happened in that sin count or 2.0 anyway
clearly our influence is felt around the
world and now that everyone hates movies
because of us movies aren't making any
money anymore
we're clearly DC fanboys we're clearly a
Marvel fan boys they used to be actual
movie critiques back in the day and now
they're just jokes they have five full
time writers and still mess stuff up all
the time they don't even seem to care
whenever they get stuff wrong like they
aren't even trying to take their job
seriously they get stuff wrong on
purpose I mean who does that my though
place Idaho it's not a real place they
hate me cuz they ain't me
everyone thinks Jeremy the narrator has
a crush on Anna Kendrick when in reality
everyone has a crush on Anna Kendrick
they smell bad stop they cheat at
YouTube by using key words and good
timing another SEO hacks material the
movie is based on doesn't matter unless
it does the answer is magic
the answer is demons have to weaken the
victim to grow stronger so that they can
officially do their evil and why
question the actions of an asshole team
in any way prior to cinemasins
toxic movie fans didn't exist on my best
and Jake low it's it's up they think
they're so smart and damn are cheap yeah
I used to nitpick movies it's a tough
racket they can't even get infinity
right you can't have infinity sins it's
not a number cinemasins
so we're gonna add infinity more to your
school by the way what happened on that
cent counter 2.0 anyway
ten years man ten Kermit and Miss Piggy
[Laughter]
exactly I hope you're gonna go I'll meet
the Feebles on this oh we have to
because Kermit the Frog because he is a
frog yep has a cloaca hurry but coming
the Frog by definition as a frog has a
clue